it's Flag Day and it's the president's
birthday and we're the ones getting all
the presents for that birthday on the
economy Foreign Affairs standing among
the international community even sports
we will observe something that
conservatives usually hate to
acknowledge which is that things are
getting better then the FBI is Inspector
General concludes James Comey and the
FBI tried to hurt Donald Trump and
helped Hillary Clinton in other news the
sky remains blue and water remains wet
we will analyze all of those important
news stories and then the god-king
Jeremy boring himself will stop by to
explain why soccer is a threat to
Western civilization finally the mailbag
and a few of my favorite American flags
for Flag Day
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so much to get to today I want to recap
a little bit on our talk with Tom Arnold
yesterday too before we get to that we
got to make a little money honey and
thank a great sponsor just in time for
Father's Day
man crates so you know this the trouble
with Father's Day is you might know what
to get your mother your sister your
whatever your brother or this you ask
your father what do you want for
Father's Day or your birthday or this I
said well don't get me anything wrong
and then you know you get him a tie or
something and he's either disappointed
because that's not a good gift or you
know you don't get him anything and then
he's sad and feels disrespected this is
all solved with man crates man crates is
a great gift you've heard us talk about
them a lot give the gift to your father
that he's guaranteed to love with man
crates hand-picked and packaged gifts
for every type of dad there's the knife
making kit that's for the hands-on dad
it's not exactly like for me if my
children were getting me I wouldn't want
that I would want the whiskey
appreciation crate which I already got
for Christmas and it's fabulous
fathers who like the finer things will
like this you know it's got this really
cool decanter and then it's got these
spherical ice cube makers and cool
glasses and it's great I really use it
all the time you know right when I wake
up in the morning I there's no no better
way to start sitting down to write my
show pull out that whiskey decanter from
man crates most gifts ship in a sealed
wooden crate with a crowbar so this is
the key to it I really think that we're
so decadent in our culture we don't need
more stuff we all have a lot of stuff
it's the giving a gift that matters the
experience of receiving it what it means
what it says about the relationship this
one comes in a crate with a crowbar
you're gonna open it up with a crowbar
you can have a gift wrapped in duct tape
it's just really good if you go to the
help section of the website because you
can't open it up it says try harder I
really love these guys a great gift get
your special Father's Day discount today
with a 100% satisfaction guarantee at
man crates calm slash Knowles que no
wles
this is a limited time offer only for
Father's Day go today man crates calm
slash Knowles que no wles
man crates calm slash Knowles so a lot
of chaos going on also I'm sorry before
we get to my recap of Tom Arnold and all
their birthday presents for the
president we got to talk about the
conversation the conversation is coming
up it's coming up soon and again
is gonna be the big boss ben shapiro
take a look hey gang on tuesday june
19th at 5:30 p.m. Eastern it's time to
tune in for another episode of the
conversation featuring me and Shapiro if
you're a daily wire subscriber now's
your chance to ask me all sorts of
questions like these what's your
favorite kind of movie the scene the
visuals usually require you to be
delivered cuz you are a movie buff even
like you think at all I like some of the
soft rock I like Jim Croce I like John
Denver have you ever tasted bacon no
I've never tasted bacon I've heard it's
fantastic as it is it as good as they
say I mean your god it's amazing
are you a fan of any other Chicago team
yeah I'm a Bears fan I'm also a
Blackhawks can the White Sox only win
the World Series one several hundred
years is your wife a doctor so the rumor
is that she is the conversation will be
on Facebook and YouTube for everyone to
watch but only subscribers will get
answers to their questions that's
Tuesday June 19 at 5:30 p.m. Eastern see
you then
I hope that he can finally answer that
question is your wife a doctor I've been
scratching my head for so long about
that so be sure to tune in for that now
some of you might have seen yesterday I
had this interview with Tom Arnold and
well if you missed it you should go back
and listen because it actually showed a
lot of the differences between the left
and the right but if you just want a
quick summary here is a quick recap of
my interview with Tom Arnold yesterday
Freddie the Kosmos for situational tells
you what I wrote the participative new
committee like I said my friend right
here tonight over at University where my
friend place and I'm from too many parts
samos Monday to the Arizona groom and
another person said cool and keen I do
but is mine gonna tell you right you
show you show you face in the world
daylight I'm telling you how I feel
gonna hurt your mind gun don't shoot to
kill come on come on lay it on me all
right I'm giving you one on the count of
three to show you step four let it be
I'm telling you just watch them out I
know your game what about you well I say
this guys are limiting to me that's
really true but my friend you see
nothing just wait'll I get to because
I'm bad bad come on come on that bad
really really bad you know I'm bad I'm
bad you know what you know very bad
really really bad you know I'm bad I'm
bad come on come on you know a bad bad
really really bad and the whole world
does the answer just right just tell
just tell you once again who's bad that
no that clip was a little bit slower
than the way that Tom and I were talking
yesterday but if you missed it you know
I got a lot of mailbag questions about
this I got a lot of tweets and
everything about what the interview was
like with Tom it was pretty wild or
moving pretty fast I'll I'll give my
thoughts on that in the mailbag
because I reacted to it actually
differently than I think a lot of people
think so we'll get to that later first
as president Trump's birthday to sell
right we are we're so lucky on this show
we get the best guests folks we are
gonna bring on Marilyn Monroe to sing
Donald Trump a happy birthday before an
audience of Hillary Clinton supporters
Marilyn take it away
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's incredible footage really well
done beautiful Marilyn and happy
birthday mr. president it's Donald
Trump's birthday but we're getting all
of the presents aren't we here's a quick
rundown before we bring on the god-king
to explain to pour a little cold water
on all of our happiness and KO FFA and
explain why soccer is a threat to
Western civilization to begin on the
economy new jobless claims fell again
last week meaning that the number of
Americans on the jobless rolls fell to a
forty four and a half year low could you
just imagine this so the labor market
right now is at or close to full
employment unemployment right now is is
under 4% slike 3.8 percent the Fed is
predicting it'll drop further by the end
of the year that's why the Fed is
finally raising interest rates for a
second time this year after not being
able to do that because of Barack
Obama's stagnant economy they're saying
the labor market is continuing to
strengthen that job gains are strong the
Fed says that economic activity is
rising at a solid rate layoffs right now
are very low there there are signs of
workers shortages across all sectors of
the economy 6.7 million job openings in
April people are receiving unemployment
insurance at the lowest level since 1973
there are more job openings in the
United States than unemployed workers to
fill them
imagine this in October 2016 if somebody
told you they said hey these what do you
think the headlines are going to be
under a Donald Trump presidency say I
don't know
the Western Hemisphere exploding and the
eastern hemisphere exploding I don't
know the core of the earth exploding
right that is what you would predict and
you get these absurdly good economic
data points on foreign affairs the
historic Kim jong-un summit is a big win
for the United States a Michael Goodwin
points this out in the New York Post
today there there are plenty of good
reasons to be cynical about the Iran
deal plenty of good reasons the Kim's
are murderous and deceptive there's no
reason to believe that this Kim is any
better than his father any less
treacherous the Kim's have backed out of
plenty of deals that they said they were
gonna do before and they you know
they've run right out before the ink is
dry also China might not let North Korea
denuclearize fine yep I get it there are
a lot of reasons to be cynical Goodwin
makes this great point in the post he
writes quote today should be declared a
holiday from nitpicking a time to
celebrate what has been accomplished
instead of fixating on the possible
pitfalls it's an occasion to look
forward with hope instead of backward
with suspicion and this is such an
important point conservatives sometimes
forget this because we want to like
frown all the time
cynicism is very stupid it's very stupid
that you know Norm Macdonald one of my
favorite voices in the world the great
voice of our age yesterday he referred
to something called the profanity of
cynicism in a tweet and he's so right
this is such an astute observation
cynicism is profane if the cynicism is
the the crutch of anxious people who
can't tolerate uncertainty and they're
terrified that they're gonna look
foolish if they end up being wrong and
so they don't want to have any hope or
smiling to begin with they just want a
frown and say everything's gonna be
terrible but the world is a hopeful
place
there's nothing virtuous about cynicism
you know you should be courageous you
should be a prudent certainly you
shouldn't be reckless or stupid but you
should be courageous you should be
prudent you should be manly not cynical
that's what the word courage comes from
courage comes from core from from heart
right and cynicism is discouraging takes
the heart out of everything you should
take heart could it go wrong
of course are we in the early stages of
whatever kind of nuclear deal we're
trying to work out yes what are the odds
that it works out who knows
there's a good first step take heart on
Foreign Affairs also and this is right
before we'll bring in the god-king to
pour cold water on everything we're
getting the World Cup in North America
it's gonna be this nice alliance between
Canada the United States Mexico a Donald
Trump by the way has been lobbying since
March to bring the World Cup to North
America meanwhile Los Angeles is getting
the 2028 Summer Olympics as well so
we've got two major international
sporting events that are coming to the
United States because of Donald Trump
everybody predicted that Trump would
hurt these bids because the whole world
hates him right he's you know he's
humiliating on the or allies hate us and
instead he actually helped now look I do
not care very much for the Olympics I
don't watch the Olympics other than
curling curling is one of my favorite
sports in the world
but other than curling I don't like it I
also think that soccer basically should
be outlawed in the United States but it
is a very good sign nonetheless of this
global leadership the United States has
global leadership president Trump has
picked up two major international
sporting events that's a good thing so
say I now I think the god-king the the
founder of my feasts and the man who
signs my checks disagrees with me on
this can we bring on the god-king hey
look it's Donald Trump's birthday it's
Flag Day I'm feeling so good
tell me bring me down what's interesting
to me is how everyone who supports the
president uh-huh carries water for the
president you can't just be a general
fan of the guy you have to be basically
an evangelist you're Donald
proselytizing ff' and so when he says
for example he calls Kim Jong than
Rocket Man never offers things like yes
we have always wanted war on the Korean
Peninsula and when he says things like I
really trust in there it's like yes we
have always wanted peace on the Korean
Peninsula and no one ever knows where
they stand with you people and this is
the greatest example this is a microcosm
yeah of all things Trump that one of the
great arguments on behalf of Donald
Trump is he's going to be a global
leader he's going to rebuild America's
supremacy he's going to salvage Western
civilization America great and make
America great again he's gonna salvage
Western civilization and now you're
that he is bringing this bastard sport
of soccer to the United States
this is Obama level leading from behind
you call that global leadership global
leadership is called baseball
yes that's baseball maybe four but
global leading from behind yeah
it's called soccer I have to say when I
was reading all the good news today well
we'll get to the we'll get to the great
explanation because I have to say this
is the best never Trump argument that
really sort of compels me before we get
to this we got to make a little money
honey we got to keep the lights on in
here keep me employed by this guy we got
to talk about Boleyn branch sheets and I
love Boleyn branch sheets you need to go
out there and buy Bolin brand sheets not
only cuz they're so so good but because
when enough of you buy Bolin brand
sheets they'll like me more and send me
more Bolin brand sheets and they're the
best thing that I've ever slept on there
your job literally depends on how well
okay you can sell these volyn branchy
might not only my job but also my
private life is your confidence in the
Bolin branch sheets such that you would
bet your job on it I uh I would
absolutely bet my job on it because I'll
tell you something there's not a lot
that we can all agree on you know for
instance we were talking in the Father's
Day episode when it comes to sleeping
sweet little ELISA mrs. Knowles and I we
prefer different things for instance I
enjoy sleeping on like a firmer mattress
she prefers sleeping on a mattress that
I'm not on but we both love Boleyn
branch sheets they are the they're the
best sheets I've ever slept on they're
made from 100% pure organic cotton they
start out very soft they get softer as
it goes on I didn't know this in my
bachelor days you probably know this you
go out you buy the cheapest sheets
they're made of sandpaper and they're
well for people who don't live in LA you
may not know that we actually buy our
sheets in LA at gas stations we do
history people set up tables out in
front of gas stations and they sell
sheets and the thread count is always
measured in single digits yes it is I
love a nice solid eight eight thread
count is really strong and firm so I
tried these nice sheets nice sheets cost
like $1,000 unless you go direct a
Boleyn branch they cut out the middleman
they cost just a couple hundred bucks
thousands of five-star reviews Forbes
Wall Street Journal Fast Company all
talking about them three u.s. presidents
leap on bull and branch sheets three
u.s. presidents one blank book author
into God king sleep on Boleyn branch
sheets shipping
you can try them for 30 nights if you
don't love them send it back for a
refund you're not gonna send them back
you're not going back to that gas
station don't do it baby get started
right now you and my listeners get $50
off your first set of sheets at Bowen
branch com promo code Michael mi CH AE L
that's a birthday present for the
president's birthday Boland branch comm
$50 upper set of sheets bol L and branch
comm promo code Michael
what's so bad about soccer what's so bad
about soccer
it's like saying Jeremy yeah
everything's going really well I noticed
in in a world history until like the
late 1930s what went wrong
soccer is listen I actually don't hate
soccer you know I I think that soccer is
a perfectly good sport for the third
world and that's what it is it's the
sport of the third world because all you
need is something roughly the size of a
ball doesn't have to be able doesn't
human head would work and I think that's
probably how it all started and you need
a patch of relatively flat earth and
then you need a bunch of people to chase
after the rolling object and
occasionally fall down as though they
had been hit yeah
pretend it hurts pretend it hurts that
is soccer and that's fine because
everyone needs sports yes
sports teach children about competition
they teach children about work ethic
they teach children a set of rules and
how to succeed within those rules and
sports help adults too because they give
us an opportunity to play out a
competitive aggression in a controlled
way that doesn't result in violence
although sometimes at soccer games the
fans actually participate in the greater
contact sport than the players through
those hooligans hooligans yeah but you
know they bring us together they give us
a sense of of pride it's a nice
distraction from the hardship of life
everyone needs that yeah and so I'm I am
glad that Ghana has a soccer team it's
good yeah I'm glad that the Ivory Coast
has a soccer team I am offended however
that Great Britain also participates in
this I'm and I am mortally offended that
the United States would condescend to
have a soccer team I tend to agree -
except for six-year-old children and
it's it's good yeah well it's really
good I wonder at the World Cup now is
because it's gonna be a host
by Canada the United States and Mexico
who is gonna provide the minivans to
pick up the players afterward and give
them juice boxes and cracker snacks
exactly tell him tell him good boy it
listen it matters when Great Britain was
in her ascendancy the height of the
British Empire she had the most complex
sport in the world cricket cricket
whatwhat did days - bleh sorry no one
understands that the smartest guy on the
block doesn't understand it that is the
sport of an ascendant power America in
her ascendancy had baseball a complex
sport the offense the defense has
possession of the ball fly rule infield
fly rule yeah those are the sports of an
ascendant nation they're complicated
they're intelligent more importantly
they're expensive because our sports
reflect something about us you can't
play baseball with just a ball and a
piece of flat earth right right bait the
recent little children play soccer is
because it's the simplest sport you
basically chase the moving ball that's
all that's require a ton of training and
specialized this and that's right and
doesn't require money now America is a
superpower
our sport really we don't have to like
it but the truth is its football right
that is the national pastime that is the
national pastime of our generation it is
the most complex and expensive sport
ever conceived the pads alone would
break the GDP of many nations that have
perfectly serviceable soccer team that's
true and that's not bad again I'm not
against third world nations having
soccer I am against us saying that
that's as good as baseball or football
and I'm against the idea that we need to
reach down and play the sport of the
world instead of showing actual global
leadership and saying no the entire
world needs to be rich enough and
powerful enough to play sports that
require you not only to chase something
but to spend thousands upon thousands of
dollars preventing brain damage that's
true and you know it's maybe we need
like a new Marshall Plan I would be
perfectly willing I'm a fiscal
conservative so are you if we could
invest in the infrastructure required to
create booming economies such that these
third-world countries can buy very
expensive and elaborate equipment to
play real sports that are
civilized absolutely I would do it in a
second I think that absolutely I agree
if Trump were to scratch his
infrastructure plan and instead you know
support the world becoming baseball and
football players yeah I'd vote for him
for sure for re-election
what I don't like though is this game of
equality being a sort of the Thatcher
view of equality that you know the left
you can be here and poor people can be
here in the less thinks it's bet the
world is a better place if everyone's
down here that's right That's not me I
think that we should set an example in
the world and give some give people
something to rise up to and that thing
is not chasing a rolling human head
across a flat patch that is exactly
right and it's so it is this degrading
going back and it's bad for us that we
yeah it's a and it's not as violent you
know there's that there's that other
aspect if you're a rich powerful
ascendant company you can take some hits
you can weather some you know you can
pay for expensive hospitals that's right
they used to flood the Coliseum and play
out in naval battles from antiquity at
the height of the decadence of Rome I
feel like we can do much the same that's
right and we should mm-hm not only that
but I think that part of the problem
with the rise of soccer in America is
that you can trace it one to one to the
decline of our culture mmm right when
America was putting a man on the moon
were grown adults in the freest country
on Earth playing soccer Michael no they
were not they were not because all that
scrap metal was going to the Space
Shuttle and not to make more minivans to
keep Pikul of people of the field that's
that's exactly right and by the way ever
since women started to enter the
workforce right that's right more women
in the workforce yeah more soccer fields
in the United States of America look at
that's just science that's a correlation
how do you even do you even study
science you even study correlates with
divorce rates it yeah I'm sure it does
someone do the math you know you've made
a really compelling argument it is the
first anti-trump argument that has
really started to convince listen I'm
not anti Trump I'm a Trump skeptic
Trump has done a lot of things that make
me very very happy mm-hm
this is not one of them I feel like if
if previous Jeremy that's Jeremy from
2016 yeah who was busy expressing off
his concerns about the worst case
what will happen if Donald Trump becomes
president you know I was worried the
Republican Party would fracture I was
worried we would lose credibility with
Millennials who are becoming the largest
voting bloc I was worried that we would
lose our principles in service only of
our of our victories yeah I never
thought that I would see the President
of the United States cheering the
ascendancy of soccer yeah I'm sorry you
make a great point
I'm mr. president I hope you're watching
it's been such a good you know it's been
such a good year and a half but please
you've got to rethink this you've got to
rethink what you're doing mr. god-king
thank you for being here thank you gotta
get Tommy the chief executive dog was
here I don't know CED is there any way
to lift him up get on stuck because this
is my real boss right here this would be
the chief yeah he also sleeps on Boland
branch that's because we're very wealthy
decadent country thank you sir always
good to see the god-king all right do we
have time to we got a little bit of time
to wrap up on the FBI before we have to
get to the mailbag okay the investigator
a general and Michael Horowitz who's the
FBI watchdog he is concluded that a
James Comey
has deviated from a bureau and Justice
Department procedures in handling the
Clinton probe which damaged the agency's
image I know you're shocked aren't you
sure we didn't think we thought they did
everything just right we thought James
Comey totally aboveboard not political
at all turns out that was all why they
wrote quote this is from the IG report
by departing so clearly and dramatically
from FBI and department norms the
decisions negatively impacted the
perception of the FBI and the department
as fair administrators of justice now
they say that there's no evidence this
was politically motivated what does that
mean what we know is the James Comey
treated Hillary Clinton differently than
he would have treated other people and
we know that they were trying to this
was during a presidential election they
were what is not political about that
anything involving Hillary Clinton is
political that's it that's absolutely
absurd
the report also by the way uncovered
previously hidden text messages that the
FBI was just not release it was just
totally covering up between disgraced
FBI agents and saucy lovers Peter struck
and Lisa
Paige Paige writes quote Trump's not
ever going to become president right
right
- which struck responds no no he won't
we'll stop it it's like the worst
saddest soy boy flirting I've ever heard
also also probably criminal and
anti-american and anti-constitutional he
said Peter struck of the FBI key
investigators saying we will stop Donald
Trump from becoming president what more
evidence do you need what more evidence
do you people need now right now at this
moment the left and the anti-trump right
are trying to lionize the FBI and
demonize the president there are all of
these distractions right there you're
looking at this you're seeing a text
from Peter struck and a key investigator
at the FBI that says we're gonna stop
Trump from being president they say look
at stormy Daniels so what what do I care
about some porn store they said look he
said naughty words on a video tapes the
FBI is saying he's gonna stop a
interfere in a presidential election
beyond the smoke and mirrors who has the
better track record here who looks
better who looks good who looks dirty
between Donald Trump and the FBI it's no
question it's no question and so it's a
happy birthday
eat soccer notwithstanding I guess it's
good we nabbed these international
sporting events and I use sporting
loosely but you know we got to be
careful here folks we can't let our
exuberance get away with us and do
things like like try to elevate soccer
as a sport oK we've got a lot of mailbag
to get to then i want to talk about my
favorite flags for Flag Day you got them
on my desk right here so by now this
isn't this is a new announcement you
have surely heard that the Michael
Knowles show is available on Amazon
Alexa and the Google home so I don't
want you to be confused
there was a video going around YouTube
that was just an Alexa commercial but
somebody replaced the all the sound with
clips from my show so it's just me Alexa
answering as me like I'd become Alexa
this is this is sort of like that I am
now on Alexa as well if you use one of
these virtual assistants you can get my
podcast with a simple voice command you
just have to enable the skill on Alexa
or ask Google to talk to the show for
more information check out our pinned
tweets daily wires pin tweets on
Facebook and Twitter just starts
screaming incoherently
think that's what that's what starts to
put my show on on the Alexa app you got
to go over right now I gotta say goodbye
to Facebook and YouTube but I'm still
saying hello to Alexa I guess I guess
we're still in there go to daily
wire.com subscribe you get me you got
the Andrew Klavan sure you get the Ben
Shapiro sure you get to ask questions
I'm the mailbag in the next one is the
big boss himself you get to do all of
that for ten bucks a month or $100 for
an annual membership it is so simple man
go over there right now we're going to
get to the mailbag right away we'll be
right back
mmm oh that's did I forget to mention
something did I forget to mention what
you get when you subscribe ooh you know
what that tastes like today it's got
this distinct flavor of 3.8%
unemployment it's got this distinct
flavor of 44 and a half year low in
jobless claims it's just mmm it's really
good haven't tasted in a long long time
very delicious though let's get to the
mailbag before we have to go from Tyler
dear Knowles the smoking jacket in
combination with the bow tie was truly a
sight to see my question is how do you
explain the irony of the all-powerful
argument in relation to God for example
can God create an object too heavy for
him to lift or can he lift anything
meaning he's not powerful enough to
create that object from Tyler yeah this
this stupid question I'm sorry I don't
mean to insult you Tyler this question
is so stupid so the question is can God
create an object so heavy that he can't
lift it this was asked in the Father's
Day video the god-king said Jeremy
boring lower case G lower case k said
that yes God can create an object so big
that he can't lift it and then he would
create a mechanism to lift it that's a
that's a interesting explanation of
Christianity I would put it differently
though basically the same point and this
is a big difference between Christianity
and Islam in the Christian religion and
the Christian God submits himself to
logic he is not a god of infinite pure
irrational wrath he's a God of logic in
the beginning was the word the logos and
the logos was with God and the logos was
God the logos being the divine logic of
the universe it is a perfectly logical
God a God who submits himself to the own
logic that he creates and so the
question can God create a rock so heavy
that he can't lift it is basically akin
to saying god bla bla bla bla bla bla
right it's like saying parrot yellow
elephant banana
four times green it is words like there
are words together but it doesn't have
any meaning it doesn't have any any
internal logic so in short answer to
your to your question this God is a God
of logic that's not true of other
religions the God of Islam is not a God
that is bound by logic it is a god that
can do what it can act very capriciously
and do whatever he likes that's a that's
a different God it's a different object
of worship and it's a different culture
that comes out of those things but ours
is a god of logic and there is a
mechanism by which God lifts that that
rock that seems so heavy that he can't
lift it and it's and it's God giving His
only begotten Son to be incarnate to die
for the sins of man that's a that's a
pretty beautiful logical way to solve
that problem from Lynn dear Michael I'm
listening to your interview with Tom
Arnold right now
you deserve an Emmy for keeping your
composure had he'd do it thanks Lynn if
you didn't see the interview it was
pretty wild as ésta marled famously is
he's a pretty wild guy I gotta say
though because some some people kind of
got it I think and some people gave
these were saying pretty mean things
about Tom I genuinely like Tom Arnold I
do I really like the guy think he's a
nice guy I think he's a genuine guy he's
not he's really not rude regardless of
what you saw in that interview I think
he's a really nice guy who's a little
out there on some of his premises so he
said something very important yesterday
about the difference between the left
and the right right now he was so honest
in his answer because I said Tom here
are the facts and he said I yeah I don't
care about that I don't care and I said
but Tom there's just one reality because
he said well this is how I feel and this
is what it seems to me and if you're
this and that Andrew and I said but
there's one reality he said no there
isn't there are multiple realities
reality is subjective there's no such
thing as objective truth and that is the
disagreement between the left and the
right that's the underlying premise that
is why the left and the right just talk
past each other is the right is saying
there is an objective reality within and
without an objective reality we couldn't
communicate
no way to communicate between people
there's no way to do anything there's no
way to understand any aspect of the
world and the left says da da da da da
da da right there there it's as radical
subjectivism there's a radical
willfulness that that's born into this
modern era that largely comes from
Nietzsche and this is radical but it
goes back further than that it goes back
to the early parts of the modern era all
the way to the 16th century or prior
could go back to the 14th century this
rejection of reality and Tom beautifully
and honestly showed that that the the
right is living in reality and the left
at its extremes and its craziness is
denying reality when you deny reality
things don't turn out very well from
Laurie hi Michael I've been thinking
about it recently I want to know your
opinion on the death penalty and when it
should be used and when not and what
methods of executing a prisoner are
humane and not humane I think it should
be used I support the death penalty I
think there were medical and health
benefits to capital punishment people
don't talk about this enough father
Rutte lerm i friend and priest in new
york wrote a wonderful piece on this I
am quoting dr. Johnson who says you can
depend upon it sir when a man knows to
be hanged in that he's going to be
hanged in a fortnight it concentrates
his mind wonderfully people should be
hanged for crimes there is justice this
is not an anti-christian a suggestion
there's it's not anti-catholic it's not
ooh
it's quite clear from the Scriptures
that capital punishment is a right of
the civil authority and we so as a
result there is something that's cruel
and unusual I think about our criminal
justice system which is that people can
languish in prison for decades and
decades and decades losing their mind
I think that's cruel and unusual I think
that's not human in the old days you
could sleep it off at night or you could
be in jail for a short period of time or
you could be in jail turning small big
rocks into small rocks for five years or
you would be hanged this to me is a much
more humane probably than letting
someone languish in isolation for
decades upon decades slowly depriving
them of their Liberty and their humanity
and as for the methods yeah they should
be clean and easy I think it was Henry
the Eighth who ordered a special
guillotine from France that would be
extra sharp for his wives never let it
be said that he was a bad husband huh
that's in short this is unpopular today
among the touchy-feely people and the
people who want to pervert religion to
advance their sentimental points of view
but there are plenty of good arguments
for capital punishment and and when you
let criminals run free there are plenty
of bad things that happen to society
from Jacob hey Michael I guess this will
probably have to end on this one if we
have now we got a couple minutes left
hey Jacob hey Michael s he am I just
having a conversation with my mailbag
right now hey Michael as a conservative
college student studying neuroscience
and political science what advice do you
have to make sure I balance my time
between schoolwork fun confronting
leftist campus lies and also looking
into the future for my career love the
show and hope to see you at U Michigan
soon that's right I think I'm coming to
you Michigan soon we'll try to have to
hash that out so there are three things
you can do in college I frequently said
there's a time and a place for
everything in that place is college
there are three things you can do work
play sleep and you can pick two I think
basically you can pick two this this is
what we were told when I was in college
this is basically how I lived in college
I slept I remember my sophomore year I
slept no more than four hours a night
every single night for at least a full
semester I was taking five classes some
of which met every day I was doing I
think five plays I was directing an
opera I was doing a lot of political
work running a campaign starting a new
campaign I was going out of my mind I
did not sleep I was going out frequently
you know going to parties and things
like that and I don't regret it at all
it's very important the social aspect of
college is very very important don't let
anybody tell you otherwise and the
academic aspect is very important and
the academic aspect is highlighted by
the social aspect because you'll learn
something or you'll read something and
then you'll talk to your friends and and
you'll have to argue about that or if
your classes are total left-wing
nonsense then your friends might say hey
read this little book this isn't being
taught in your political philosophy
class but read this one this might
change your thoughts so don't disregard
the play at all you might have to
disregard
sleeeeep don't be unhealthy about it but
you know it college is a tough time and
it's very compact you're trying to fit
in your education into four years I'm
not one of these guys who's anti college
really I mean colleges have been so
corrupted and hollowed out by the left
that it's very frustrating but I really
believe in liberal education i I don't
think you should just do some trade you
know and say okay if you don't study
engineering it's not worth getting an
education I don't believe that for one
second I think the humanities are
basically the essence of they create the
stuff of our consciousness and will
really help us to come closer to our
politics and to know ourselves and to
know God better so you got it you got to
really dive into it and you know don't
don't disregard the party part either
you know this is there's a time and a
place for everything pal okay could we
get one more question then do we have
time for one one more one more she says
okay from Dean hey Knowles I was curious
about your thought your thoughts were on
the Republican Party's stance on things
that are objectively bad for the
environment like the Keystone pipeline
and expansion of offshore drilling just
because things are hard to conserve does
that mean we should not do it
furthermore if you do not believe these
things are harmful to the environment
and surrounding ecosystems can you
provide information as to why many
thanks for what you do my mom and I love
your show thank you to both of you for
watching even that phrase is giving away
the whole premise to the left harm the
environment because what
environmentalists do is they they make
the environment the rocks and the trees
and the water seemed like morally
conscious actors so they
anthropomorphize things that are not men
that don't have moral qualities to them
they say oh you're harming the
environment what am i harming the earth
is a rock I can't I'm not gonna harm a
rock though the rock isn't gonna start
crying because I harmed it mother nature
isn't gonna weep that is crazy nonsense
we are here and we have dominion over
the earth and over the birds of the air
and the fish of the sea and the animals
that prowl around the ground and
everything else around there we have
dominion over that we need to take care
of it why do when you have to take care
of it so that we can enjoy it not
because it has
right not because you know it is
deserving of some natural right or
something it's for us we should be good
stewards because we love the earth and
we and we love our civilization in our
society I don't see evidence that the
advantages to all of humanity into
civilization and lifting people out of
poverty and allowing people to do new
things and create more wealth and have a
more opportunity to explore their
interests and to explore culture and to
explore their God and to have a
relationship with their God I don't
think that which all comes out of the
ground in a beautiful little liquid
called oil and natural gas when I don't
think that the harming a few delta smelt
or something is is a reason not to have
any of those things you have to ask
yourself what is the purpose of the
environment what is the purpose of these
is it because it's a moral actor with
just as many rights as I have in just
the same points of life as I have no of
course not absolutely not
so you have to ask yourself if the costs
do do outweigh the benefits then you
don't do something but I see no evidence
of that with an oil pipeline or pumping
more oil out of the ground drill baby
drill because we're making America great
again and that's and that's a good thing
it's a good thing that we'll be more
prosperous and we'll be able to give
more to charity and we'll be able to
live fuller lives and to explore both
our physical enjoyments and our
metaphysical enjoyments okay that's it
we got a lot of good questions I had a
really good one that someone was gonna
ask me about why Ben and I disagree on
the values of partisanship we'll just
have to get to that next time we'll have
to get to that now I'll be a team player
it's Flag Day very briefly some early
American flags everybody remembers this
one this is the Betsy Ross flag with the
circle of stars that's good they say
this is the first American flag that
isn't true the the first flag that we
know was used by George Washington is
this flag and appeal to heaven it's the
Pinetree flag and on top it says an
appeal to heaven this is referencing
John Locke it's a it's a refutation of
the Divine Right of Kings and it's
saying we're not going to accept the
Divine Right of Kings if they're doing a
bad job we're going to appeal to his
king which is an appeal to heaven it's
an interesting first flag that a lot of
people don't
reference and then one of my favorite
flags obviously there's the Gadsden flag
which is that symbol of America the
rattlesnake always a symbol of these
colonies don't tread on me a wonderful
symbol of that American can do get out
of here pal don't you f with me kind of
spirit that's a good one
but my favorite one is the Grand Union
Flag this was the first national flag of
the United States
it looks like an American flag with the
stripes but it's got the Union Flag in
there the the British flag in that top
corner where the stars are and I really
like this one and I'm glad it was the
first national flag of the United States
because it shows that we're not these
radical revolutionaries who are cutting
ourselves off from tradition we're
inheriting a tradition from the old
world and from the country that helped
establish this country and there's a
there's a long institutional history
that goes back and I think it really
grounds the American Revolution and
something that's different than the
French Revolution we don't start cutting
off people's heads or in you know
cutting off our king's head and trying
to undo everything and burning down
churches and creating new cults of
reason what we do instead is we we take
from the tradition and we keep what is
so valuable about it we have a
continuity with our our forebears who
were pretty good guys and and great guys
okay that's our show today we're at a
time I'm sorry folks I got to go and get
out of here so I will see you on Monday
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Noel's show have a good weekend
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you